a couple of years ago for the Milwaukee
Bucks and he made the most of his
opportunity Gary frontiersman filling it
up since he's locked in the gym
Gary trans jr. behind the wall
it is Stokes and a triple as they're up
by six thirteen two to run for them
finally got on the board after a dry
spell and filling it up again bound
rhythm with that little crossover didney
Gary friend jr. well short on wings when
I look at what happened in Milwaukee
this year you know I became a buck Stan
I want to watch those bumper was up a
guy that was a catalyst in the second
quarter
Trent junior behind a wall that's a good
wall and he gets to the free-throw line
watch Jarnell Stokes watch high comes up
that's the first screen Tucker gets
through that flip see right Wilson found
it on the run how many times you get to
be Jerry West
nobody maybe you'd be long time I don't
know buddy for the first half back out
there but this is the guy they wanted to
develop Gary Trent junior and
the baby feel like they belong will
hesitation right there plays at
different speeds 5 plus to play in the
third 10 minute session only 10 minutes
check that where you wanted to go and
that's been the story is recruit ranked
junior miss cousin yep like it all other
twin junior you can get it outside bias
top and working with people like you you
know many people live work good oh just
silly but it's fun yeah and we don't
forget step back for training for week
five week missions and a lot of
experiences do the animate with a good
of the lead tread you in your long -
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure you
subscribe for some more video content